what disappointment did you experience  with defense what do you think they're  thinking and and they really know me I  mean I I first thing I do I get up I  make a good morning Story I mean I'm  filming stories all throughout the day  every single day you know to let people  in yeah and I think uh I don't know how  really to answer this other than um I  let them all down you know um  I said that I didn't do this thing I  said that I didn't do steroids this  whole time you know and I've been doing  them and so I think that when you're  dishonest with with somebody when you  mislead somebody I believe that what  they feel is betrayed you know and and  so what I try to share back is  um  first thing I always want to say is I  apologize for this I did this I did this  I own that and and I know what I did was  wrong